E aí
bom
hoje vou ensinar para fazer uma mini
catapulta use-a de materiais muito
básicos
depois que é que vocês podem fazer com
ela
e
a já seja segundo um amigo de um amigo
um amigo qualquer coisa assim falou que
eles vez quiseram que foi a maneira Mc
maltesa e processados Nakata [ __ ]
mandavam com outra pessoa apanhar com a
boca e tenho que era aquilo do verão
muito difícil mas pronto divertimos para
caraças
Oi e eu eu nunca fiz eu só ouvi falar e
tu que ia falar para vocês e pronto
vocês podem fazer isso lá em casa o
tutorial demora muito e pronto os
materiais vão ter todos em casa é
e
para fazer essa curta você arruma mala
grande e lá no escritório
uma tampinha
escola para seresta outra qualquer
e mais vamos tirar uma parte da mola e a
parte que eu não tenho ferro embriagado
sério achar na outra parte da série A
e depois eu estou microfones para ir
amanhã fazer um cruzeiro
e fui na outra extremidade a dois
centímetros centímetros de agora
depois Olá amiguinha e veja fica uma
distância ali atrás comigo depois
conseguir esperar a [ __ ] e confeccionar
puxa quer passar da tela Paraná Cola
feliz e
reforçar a conexão um elástico pode usar
mais elástico quanto mais usarem mais
forte ficar apostas e de clicar em
dá
para esperar do mundo dele à frente da
senhora é da [ __ ] puxar e te esperar